[Music]
along with the live-action version of an
animated Classic this week is filled
with streaming options about platonic
relationships Chinese mythical Gods a
CIA family and some guy named John Wick
so let's do it on this week's what to
watch
World a man was drowning I had to save
him this obsession with humans has to
stop
I just want to know more about them
surfacing in theaters
fantasy film The Little Mermaid
obviously you gotta see this one because
of course it's a live-action adaptation
of Disney's 1989 animated classic of the
same name which itself was based on the
1837 fairy tale by Hans Christian
Anderson it's a copycat business folks
Hallie Bailey stars in this iteration as
Ariel and has been getting Universal
praise for her portrayal she's also
joined by The Talented names like David
Diggs Aquafina Jacob Tremblay and
Melissa McCarthy in supporting roles
with McCarthy stepping into the
tentacles of sea witch Ursula yet
another reason to add this to your watch
list but honestly the most convincing
thing I can say is that lin-manuel
Miranda co-wrote all the songs I repeat
lin-manuel Miranda co-wrote all the
songs and better yet he did it alongside
composer Alan Menken who worked on the
original animated film soundtrack that's
a mic drop can't be friends with a girl
there's lots of famous men and women
friends Laura Dern and Sam Neal in
Jurassic Park launching on Apple TV plus
is the comedy series platonic this one
follows two former best friends played
by by Seth Rogen and Rose Byrne who
reconnect in midlife after a long Rift
and their relationship begins to
destabilize their lives and if those two
stars aren't reasoned enough to watch
how about the fact that they reunited
with Siri's co-creator Nick Stoller who
directed some of the comedy films these
two are known for like neighbors and
neighbors too all that familiarity has
been good for the series so far with a
certified fresh score in the 90s on the
Tomato Meter and among other things top
critic Brian tolerico from the playlist
credits Rogan and burns Ace comic timing
for the show's success yeah duh the fate
of Your World hangs in the balance I
don't really see how I fit into this
whole thing from my guide
we talk about something a little bit
cooler than guide servant yeah I know
you're right guys better another
streaming option for you this week is
the comedy series american-born Chinese
this show is based on the 2006 graphic
novel of the same name and stars the
incomparable Michelle yo reason numbers
1 through 100 to watch this one by the
way the show follows a struggling boy
who meets a new exchange student and
becomes involved in a battle of Chinese
mythological Gods been there done that
to make this one even more appealing is
the fact that directors like Lucy Liu
and Destin Daniel did their work
behind the camera proving that the
talent spreads far and wide on this
series and critics seem to agree with
early reviews putting this one certified
fresh in the 90s on the Tomato Meter and
praise going toward the updates and
expansion of the source material I know
where the wmd store so follow me or get
out of my way
she clearly has daddy issues okay keep
your butt planted on the couch for yet
another streaming option this week Fubar
which sounds like another word for butt
the main reason to check out this
Netflix comedy series is that it stars
Arnold Schwarzenegger and his first
starring role in a scripted live action
series dude yes he stars as a CIA
operative nearing retirement who finds
out that his daughter played by Monica
Barbaro also works in the same
profession leading to some very
interesting family Dynamics and if
you're not already sold on this one
check out the comedy heavy Supporting
Cast that includes Fortune feimster Adam
Pally and even Schwarzenegger's old pal
Tom Arnold the good death
only comes after good life
you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend finally if you're
ready for some serious action from the
comfort of your home John Wick chapter 4
is officially streaming sitting at an
impressive certified fresh 94 on the
Tomato Meter and in 93 with the audience
many critics have already placed this
one at the top of the WIC franchise not
to mention naming it one of the best
action movies ever a fresh set of
characters helps keep things kicking
with action Legends Donnie Yen hiroyoki
Sonata and Scott Adkins doing their
thing and speaking of fresh not too long
ago chapter 4 ushered the entire
franchise into the billion dollar Club
Crossing 1.1 billion dollars globally
well there it is fresh friends five
great options to get you through the
week you're welcome be sure to let us
and your fellow viewers know in the
comments what you did check out whether
it was on this list or not remember to
check out rottentomatoes.com for the
latest updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay fresh
[Music]